في العراق ما في خبر شاغل العراقيين اكثر
من مستجدات سرقه القرن زي ما صار اسمها
وهي الفضيحه اللي تكشفت في اكتوبر لما
انكشفت سرقه مليارين ونص دولار
نعمته هذا هو المبلغ مليارين ونص دولار من
اموال الضرائب الجديد في القصه هو استرداد
جزء من المبلغ المسروق و100 واثنين
وثمانين خلينا نقول مليون مليار دينار
عراقي اللي هو بعادل 125 مليون دولار من
اصل المليارين ونصف اللي انسرقوا ومعاه
كمان تم الافراج عن احد المتهمين علشان
يجيب باقي اللي سرقوه
زهير جاسم مالك شركتي القانت والمبدعون
هذا المتهم اعتراف انه اخذ التريليون
و618 الان سلم
182 مليار مكسور
وهذه الدفعه الاولى تم الاتفاق
بين محكمه التحقيق الثانيه مع هذا المتهم
نور زهير على جدول الاسترداد كامل المبلغ
اللي هو تريليون
670 مليون دينار
حتى يسلم كل المبلغ
سيصدر القاضي المختص
امر باطلاق سراحه بكفاله يسلم الاموال
ويبقى الاجراء عند القضاء
هنا ندعو
المتهمين
الصادره بحقهم اوامر القبض في هذه القضيه
الى التسليم انفسهم وتسليم المبالغ
المسروقه
وسنعمل مع القضاء على مساعدتهم بالاجراءات
القضائيه وفوق ما يسمح به القانون
ظهور رئيس الوزراء برزم الفلوس حوالين
واثر جد الواسع فانا ستنكرت المنظر وناس
استنكرت الافراج عن متهم وناس ثانيه قالت
طب ما هو لو فضل محبوس ما حيرجع شيء وناس
تقول اللي رجع يده ب 5% من المسروق وناس
تقول يا حسره على البلد اللي اكلها الفساد
ونقاش طويل عريض شغال قوليلي كيف ممكن
ينسرق مليارين ونص دولار في اللي صار انه
تدقيق داخلي لوزاره الماليه العراقيه في
الهيئه العامه للضرائب كشف الاختلاف
التفاصيل كثيره ومعقده لكن الخلاصه انه
الفاسدين اعملوا خمسه شركات وهميه وحولوا
لها المبالغ هذه كلها من وداع ضريبيه
لشركات يعني
وقاحه على اعلى مستوى تدرس بصراحه يعني
فحولوا
مليار مو الف 2000 لالالا مليارين ونص
دولار والموضوع انكشف لما اشتكت شركه نفط
انها بالطالب بوديعتها ومعرفه تحصلها
وبدات الفضيحه وسهره استقالات واقالات
وتدقيق وتحقيق رسمي وعود بالوصول للمبلغ
وتقديم المتهمين للعداله والجديد اللي
عرضنا لكم هو اليوم يعني اول المستجدات في
التحقيق الافراج عن المتهم عشان رجع شويه
من اليسرقوا وعود انه يرجع الباقيه
العراقيين من اكتوبر موقف وكل كلام في
الموضوع وتعليقات على فداء حتى المبلغ
حسره على كم الفساد سخريه من الوضع
المضحكه المبكي وكاميرات تفاعلكم من
الشارع العراقي بعض الاصدقاء
تعتبر فهي تعتبر قطره في بحر محيط من
السرقات التي حصلت للشعب العراقي اخراج
نبضات من الفلوس السوداني طلع نبضات من
الفلوس وشنو راح يخش بشيس الشعر
بالنسبه للقضيه اللي كشفت مؤخرا بخصوص
سرقه 3 مليار استرجاع مليار فقط
في العراق سنوات